foreign
[Applause]
through my social media on my phone
and I'll get an ad
but how on Earth do they know that
sometimes I snore so loudly my brother
needs to wear earplugs the next room
over
all familiar with this not so secret
habit of the tech industry where they
use these complex algorithms to get to
know who we are what we like what we
don't like also they can tailor ads to
us and sell us things
but what if we could use this technology
for good
when I was diagnosed with depression in
2015 I had multiple intense suicidal
episodes
at one point it actually got so bad that
I spent the whole day planning out how I
would die later that evening
I was probably less than an hour away
from ending my life when something saved
me
what was it someone reached out
I now know that I'm not alone we're in
Australia suicide is the leading cause
of death for individuals aged between 15
to 44 years old
and for every single suicide death
there are 25 to 30 times the number of
attempts
our recent research has even shown us
that less than half of people who
attempt suicide will actually reach out
for help prior meaning that if we are to
reach them we need to meet them where
they are
I'm not a researcher who tries to
understand how can we do this and the
research tells us that people most
people who attempt suicide or even think
of suicide don't actually want to die
in fact they're looking for any reason
to continue on living but what that
tells us is that any sort of
interruption whether it's a tap on the
shoulder a message or even an internet
pop-up
could potentially save someone's life
so for me the question then becomes how
do we do this in a better way how can we
reach out in a more effective rapid and
far-reaching manner well we have great
hotlines and emergency services in
Australia but they still require the
individual to take the first step
but another thing is how on Earth are we
supposed to know what a person's
thinking or feeling if they're not
speaking up
one way is through their search
behaviors
because you and I both know we've
searched things up on the internet that
we would never ask another living soul
our struggles about suicide are no
exception
and the research actually supports this
for example in one study the
investigators went up to these
individuals who had recently attempted
suicide and asked to see their
anonymized search history and in fact
these individuals had searched up
keywords pertaining to a suicide means
and methodology as well as surrounding
hopelessness and loneliness another
fighting that supports this and have
been found in many different countries
for example in Japan U.S and Taiwan is
that the volume of internet searches for
suicide related terms actually
correlates with the national suicide
rate
in a completely different field they
found that us Australians we spent about
40 hours a week on the internet and 93
of the time it starts on a search page
so could it be that the search page be
an ideal place to intervene that's why
many countries including Australia if
you search up suicide related terms on
the internet you'll see a hotline Banner
which is great but the research shows
that not everybody on the verge of
taking their life wants to call a
hotline it's not as easy as picking up a
phone and calling internationally many
countries still don't have a sustainable
hotline and even in Australia if you put
in a combination of keywords in the
search bar you're not going to be shown
the hotline Banner but you're going to
get information that might actually Aid
a suicide attempt
so what if we could use the same
algorithms that these tech companies use
to tailor ads to us to be able to
identify and reach out to individuals
thinking of suicide and we use
information their age gender language
and geography to do so in a deeply
personal and engaging way
so what does this look like imagine Amy
a 22 year old girl living in Sydney she
lives with her housemates and despite
her chill for demeanor she's recently
been having thoughts of suicide
she's tried talking to her family
members but they haven't been
particularly helpful and today she
turned to the search page to find a way
to end it all
and as he's searching the algorithm
triggers and on the very first launch
he's an ad that leads her to a landing
page and that landing page is designed
to lead her away from a suicide attempt
now
on that page she's not met with overly
fluffy language or with directives you
have to do this you have to do that but
rather she's met with stories of other
people who've been where she is and
after hearing their stories she finally
decides to seek help through one of the
many options available
we work together with a group of people
that have thought of suicide
that have attempted suicide as well as
lost someone to Suicide where together
we come up with a list of keywords that
people are likely to search we come up
with what the ad is going to say and we
come up with a look and feel of the
landing page now these are the landing
pages need to be as engaging as possible
why is that because we don't know if
we're only minutes away from an attempt
that's why my team and I are using
extensive targeting for example age
language gender and geography to be able
to reach out to these individuals in a
deeply personal way where we can use the
tailoring to show different ads and
landing pages to different people
so in Australia for example what we
found is that individuals
who are in their teens perhaps will
resonate and different imagery and
different wording will resonate with
them than say somebody in their 40s or
50s for example what we found is that
the younger generation actually really
like the calming and distracting
resources they really like the breathing
exercises whereas the older generation
they don't want to see any of that and
they prefer direct no-nonsense straight
to the point language
so in Amy's case that's what she'll see
but imagine Robert a 55 year old man
living in rural Queensland
due to the recent economic downturn he's
been under a tremendous amount of stress
and because he's the breadwinner and the
man of the family he feels that he
cannot talk to anyone something we know
that is not true
and so he turned to the search page to
find out what would happen to his life
insurance policy in the event of a
suicide because he's still thinking
about his family
and as he goes there because his a group
indicated they want direct no-nonsense
problem-solving language that's what
he'll be shown
and on every single landing page there's
a welcome video and the person welcoming
you to that welcome video is somebody
from your age group
this is so that for every single person
in that dark time they'll be shown an ad
and landing page tailored as closely as
possible to them
now we've run this trial in Australia
and what did we find in just 19 days
our campaign reached over a hundred and
twenty thousand people surging up
distress and suicide related keywords
now when they're on the page we want
them to consume content that is likely
to lead them away from a suicide attempt
and that is going to promote help
seeking
now the industry standard for engagement
is approximately three percent that is
three percent of individuals who land on
the page will engage with a page in a
meaningful way we found an engagement
rate of over 22 percent
that's over seven times the industry
average
suggesting there's a real need for this
type of intervention
furthermore we're also developing Pages
for Aboriginal and Torres Strait
Islanders as well as Mandarin speaking
populations in Australia now we're doing
this in several different countries in
several different ways for example in
Indonesia where I'm from mental health
stigma is so bad that your own family
might put you in a makeshift cage for
having a mental disorder and there are
over 21 unique Regional dialects now
we're using Geographic targeting to show
different dialect pages to different
locations for example if you live in
samarang in Central Java you'll see the
adult landing page in Bahasa Java if you
live in balembang you're going to see
the page in Bahasa palinbang now our
pages are already being used in kidul
Mountain which is an area with some of
the highest suicide rates in the entire
country and we're getting reports that
it's resonating really well with people
why is that because when you speak the
national language you speak to their
minds but when you speak the regional
language the language they spoke growing
up you speak to their hearts
I'd like to leave you with this
we have an entire industry
with the technology the data and the
means to reach out to people who need it
rather than just tailor ads to them and
sell them things
and this cannot replace the role of
relationships and communities but given
that most people still don't seek help
prior to a suicide attempt this could
play an important piece of the puzzle in
making sure that every single person
in their dark time is met with an
outstretched hand the same way someone
saved me whether it's a tap on the
shoulder
a text message
or even an internet ad
thank you
[Applause]